hey I was going for us my name is FERPA
not only that biggest youtuber on
YouTube
Stefan but also the hottest you think
I'm full of [ __ ]
well I'm gonna prove it there's a
website called how hot let's just let
their super advanced technology speak
for itself we're gonna start with this
really ugly picture of me it's so ugly
but I've according to this super
advanced technology and I scan my face
at 26 years that's exactly what I am so
you know this is legit software and
let's see here how hot they think I am
do they think I'm Huma do they think I'm
ok nice hot stunning oh look at that
godlike well hot what do you know
nothing new here let's try some other
youtubers I selected some very
attractive photos of other youtubers
here we have Chuck's a great picture of
jacksepticeye let's see how hot he is
he's ok don't don't don't don't
it's just a it's just a stupid software
Jack don't don't let it get to you
dan is not on fire let's see how hot
that fire is it's ok
37 years how did they let's take this
great picture of markiplier hmm 43 what
the [ __ ] well it looks like the evidence
is pretty clear so far but let's try
some more youtubers
let's try marts yet there must be some
kind of glitch listen up Marty I'm the
hottest youtuber that's more like it
what about Smosh they're nice
I can understand at 27 that's correct -
what about ksi he's okay yeah I wouldn't
go further than I what about Tyler Oakes
can't even detect the [ __ ] face how
how can they not see the face well you
heard it here first folks Tyler Oakley
doesn't have a face zoella nice yep
sure what about Alfie he's nice I got
the age right oh boy it looks like I win
thank you thank you everyone thank you
wow it's quite the honor yeah I agree
with that one what if I take my face and
make it smaller will I still be
amazingly attractive nice nice indeed
yep you're right that is that is
definitely hot what if they take my face
and put it on someone else's body
am I still attractive
well what can I say what if we take my
face and put it on a potato stunning I'm
a stunning potato hey I'll put that on
my curriculum that potato is apparently
ha ha ha but awkward moment when a
potato is hotter than you are I can't
believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] worked I asked
you bros to post funny ones Skeletor
38 years still hi this this car is hot
and 32 years old how the [ __ ] can you
not get a face on Tyler Oakley but on a
[ __ ] car a car the [ __ ] nose the
nose is stunning so what if we try a
picture of Hitler this is an unbiased
opinion from this AI it's ok ok well
that's good scan his face Oh God
no potato people all along this changes
everything
let's run it through the program